- [Instructor] "A new solar-powered
bicycle can reach speeds
"of up to as high as 30 miles per hour."
So just as I read it, that felt awkward.
It felt like I said more
than I needed to say.
"Up to as high as 30 miles per hour."
Not even looking at the
choices, if I were to write this
in a more concise way,
in a kind of a cleaner,
more efficient way, I would say,
"new solar-powered bicycle can
"reach speeds of up to 30 miles per hour."
I don't even have to write "as
high as 30 miles per hour."
So let's see what our choices are.
So, I already said I
definitely want to change it.
So I'm not gonna pick "no change."
And just replacing this with
"up to" isn't one of these choices.
So I'm gonna have to look
a little bit more closely at these.
"A new solar-powered
bicycle can reach speeds of
"upwards and close to 30 miles per hour."
This also feels very bulky,
way more words than I need to use.
And it also doesn't make a lot of sense
to be "upwards and close to."
I mean, are they think upwards of
30 miles per hour and also close to?
It feels like a very strange phrasing,
and definitely using more
words than I need to use.
"A new solar-powered
bicycle can reach speeds of
"nearly 30 miles per hour."
Yeah, I like that.
It's actually, in some
ways it's more concise.
And actually it's one word versus
two words that I had right over here.
So I like that, "nearly."
That's very clean, very concise,
really straight to the
point, easy to read.
"A new solar-powered
bicycle can reach speeds of
"nearly 30 miles per hour."
And then over here, the last choice,
you have "nearly as high as."
So once again this feels very bulky.
It's using more words than I need to use.
When I can just use "nearly,"
why would I use "nearly as high as?"
So I would rule that one out as well.